how long does it take you to get over
the pain of that loss to angie ruiz jr
about three weeks that's quite a long
time isn't it yeah yeah you do to sleep
and I'll be thinking about it up again I
lost but you know it's cool what a
blessing is that I got the solid people
around me now been with me since day one
so they know me as AJ John saying so
that's a good thing so even though I
lost it was only in my quiet time kind
of when I was going to bed or something
like that then I'll really think about
it we're in a weird way it was like it
is like a relief though because the loss
is out of the way it's done in it yeah
quite strong minded person night you I
find them opportunity in even in the
worst so like type of cases anyway were
you embarrassed because you definitely
kept your head down kept a lower profile
for all in a way I wasn't about hiding
it was more strategically because I
think the changes I made in training you
would have been out to pick up a phone
if I was showing you right where I was
and what I was up to so it wasn't my how
to hide from any situation I feel like I
could seriously you could fill out this
arena here and I could talk about all my
losses in life and I'm proud of him you
know I mean I'm not gonna shy away from
them anyway the mental part of this
fight yeah it's probably gonna be
massive yeah a hundred percent and how
have you prepared for that just telling
yourself I always say that we belong
here this is a new to us so I feel like
yeah I took my last but that doesn't
justify me so I feel like I belong a
good level of books that will you be
more nervous on fight night than you
normally are
no wait because it's a different
situation I never know this never look
at the last bar for sleep in the ring I
know I'm good when you know you're good
assign you don't make it the biggest
thing in your life the biggest thing in
my life is actually training fighting
isn't hard the fighting and winning
isn't hard the train in every day having
a right people around you every day
that honestly that's the biggest fight
in my life the winning it's easy that
takes care of itself have you done much
psychology well I had someone late yeah
someone do sports psychology with you
think I'll do more of that
this fight no I want to get I want a
psychic you're gonna go in and knock you
out and then general they put me in a
trance there will be serious questions
about your future if you don't win this
fight
why to row against Andrew is jr.
wouldn't it be a long haul back from
there no you're not done with boxing if
he lose weight no no way less like Eddie
bins me off and every promoter doesn't
want me caught then so be it but
providing less than opportunity I will
rain again